[Music]
good afternoon everybody
how you doing that's it let's try it one
more time how you doing
excellent much better so I realize we
are sitting in between you and your
beers or whatever cocktail that you may
enjoy so you're going to try and keep
this session interactive and interesting
so my name is Ruth Paul Bogle I'm part
of the product team the apogee product
team within the Google cloud team and
I'm also going to be joined by Greg
Braille who was the principal software
engineer within the Apogee team as well
so if you're here for learning about how
you can manage api's and focus on the
full lifecycle then you are at the right
session right so pat on your back if you
made it to the right room you have heard
a lot about api's today in in the
morning keynote you heard many api has
been discussed some products being shown
we're going to try and take you to a
journey on what does the api lifecycle
look like as we see many for customers
adopting api's and using their the way
to transact digitally with many of the
businesses many of the partners and
employees and external entities you're
going to walk it through the role of the
API team this is a team who's
traditionally responsible for working
standing up api's securing them so on
and so forth so today is going to be a
very interactive session we're going to
dual back and forth between slides and
demos to kind of give you a taste of how
that experience looks like
so why ap is when you hear about things
such as digital transformation
essentially means many modern
enterprises today are transacting the
business api's so all the core
capabilities that have been locked in
some systems of record such as ERP
systems some of the systems which are
homegrown are now unlocked with a BIS in
this modern world which means you can
take to the api's and
not only creates some excellent
productivity applications internally you
can take them out to your partners and
build this whole ecosystem in the
morning in the keynote if some of you
guys got a chance to attend that the
different kinds of ecosystems by
partners employees and then even an
outside wall to the industry and then
external entities API are becoming more
and more central to every organization
that is trying to participate in the
data world we take a slightly opinion
view about api's and we start with what
we call as the digital value chain it's
actually a very simple concept if you
think about it at the end of the day all
what matters is the entity to your left
or my right which is the customer or the
end user it's all about delivering
delightful and connected experiences to
those end users through an app an app
can be of any kind could be a mobile app
could be an app which is built in the
web or even a set-top box well their
developers who build those apps right
and they build those apps using velka
reddit api's which are managed by an API
team and this API team comprises of API
developers who will use a platform such
as Apogee edge to manage secure publish
those api's and essentially the API
layer really sits on top of any back-end
system that you may have it could be
something which is already service
enabled it could be an old system which
has some slope based API is perhaps or
perhaps you have some legacy systems
which are unlocked using some kind of a
middleware solution ok so we're going to
examine what the data really chain is
and how you can essentially use these
core constructs to do something very
simple it's all about ensuring that you
have massive adoption of the api's as
you start on a digital journey
and start to transact more and more
through api's adoption is key it's only
as good as you know people using your
api's that they are gonna start giving
you the benefits that they promised it's
also about scale you need to be able to
rely on a platform that can support
massive scale and we're talking about
internet scales as a platform Apogee
edge supports billions of API calls in a
day in the cloud and we have several of
our customers who are actually
supporting the exact same capacity in
their own datacenters today it's also
birth control ensuring that people have
this awesome experience comes at a cost
you want to ensure that if API are the
way you are transacting your business
it's done in a careful curated way you
have a lot of security around ensuring
that only the people or the entities or
the apps who should get access to the
api's do so and in the end all the tools
and the platform capabilities really put
a focus on trying to give you all that
at a very fast pace or agility okay so
I'm going to turn over to Greg for this
piece he's gonna walk us through what
the apogee edge platform is all about
and then both he and him and me are
gonna duel back and forth ensuring you
through a live demo of the journey of an
API developer and how they use a
platform to build api's Greg excellent
hey I'm Greg I'm gonna be talking a
little bit about the apogee platform and
a little bit about what we actually do
here so people always ask what is Apogee
do if we looked at that digital value
chain there were really two things that
were happening we were connecting the
developers the people who build apps
that use api's with the API team the
people who actually create the API is
that they use and for that we have to
have things like developer portals
documentation self-service onboarding
tools so that a developer can click on a
button and get the security credentials
they need to make API calls right away
there's also a technical connection
where we're doing things like adding
security to API calls doing rate
limiting caching transforming api's from
one format to another the Appaji edge
product is responsible for doing really
both of those things and if we look at
the components of the product there are
a couple of different pieces down at the
bottom is what I'm talking about between
the application and the API itself we
have a set of runtime services and
that's where we can insert policies and
v falls gonna show you how we create
those policies and what they can do and
those policies can do all sorts of
things like I said security rate
limiting you know you'll get the whole
story there and then on top they're a
bunch of services that enable that so
for instance there's a management
component that is responsible and
supplies both a user interface and an
API for manipulating all of these
components programming the proxies
configuring the developers and the
applications and everything that prif
balls gonna do in the UI has an
Associated API as well
they're also a set of developer services
those are the developer portals and the
tools that we can use in order to
construct a web presence for our API so
a developer can really you know connect
and learn how to use the API and their
set of analytic services that are
gathering metadata about all of the API
traffic and presenting it in different
ways so that you can report on it create
custom reports and see all sorts of
information about how the API is being
used now
Appaji and is a product for all this
companies such as Google have API
management systems that they built
themselves for their own API so what
Apogee edge really is is a product that
allows anybody to create the API
management system that they need for
their API and that fits in with with the
requirements of their enterprise now I
don't know if any of you are
Appaji customers already but I wanted to
talk a little bit about actually how the
product is deployed the entire product
we described there actually can run in a
couple of different form factors we
deliver it as a service it's available
as the service which means everything
you see in the demo today it's all
multi-tenant self-service cloud app just
as you gone come to expect from the
Google cloud platform where Appaji is
actually sitting in between API calls
being made from the client to the server
and it's actually the runtime is going
through our cloud the entire product is
also a
for on-premises deployment so we have a
number of customers typically large
customers who have lots of data centers
because contrary to what we might say
sometimes there's still a lot of data
centers out there in the world and
customers often want to have their API
and all of their API traffic and all of
the management of it controlled by their
own software running in their own data
center and finally there's a hybrid
model and I'm gonna get to that a little
bit because that's some very interesting
stuff that is starting to emerge that is
starting to meet our customers where
they really want to be if you look at
sort of the traditional way to use
apogee sort of a big big product that
sits in the middle so if we look on the
top you may have mobile apps and web
apps that are making API calls from the
internet to backends that are down on
the bottom within an enterprise network
and in using the apogee edge as a
service typically Apogee is running in
the Internet the API traffic is going to
Apogee somewhere in the cloud and it is
actually connecting back to the backend
and interestingly enough the runtime
component of apogee edge can run in the
Google cloud it can also run in the
Amazon Cloud because the truth is we
have a lot of customers out there whose
API backends are already in Amazon and
we're committed to making sure that that
runtime is available in both of those
locations so that people can choose and
they can put their api proxies where
they actually need them to be based on
the geography of their actual network
but we also offer a hybrid option and
that hybrid option allows you to have
the API gateway the thing that proxies
the traffic located wherever you want
without having the rest of Apogee come
with it
so things like analytics and management
of the API stuff come as a service or as
the Gateway itself becomes something
that you can deploy on your own network
so what one of the things we're doing
this week is we're actually introducing
a new option for the apogee edge product
called edge hybrid and we're actually
announcing an early access program that
we're signing up selected customers for
this week and what that's allowing us to
do is allowing us to mix and match and
have sort of the best of both of these
worlds for the runtime components the
analytics components and the control
components stay in as a service within
Apogee but the Gateway itself the
proxies the traffic can go anywhere
and we're introducing a new open source
component that we're calling a PID and
one of the things that a PID does is it
sort of acts as an API for API
management so it offers services for
things like verifying API keys you know
computing distributed quota values and
gathering API analytics and then we
could have a variety of gateways that
actually run in your own data center or
inside of kubernetes container or inside
pivotal Cloud Foundry or wherever you
need them to be that can then use a PID
to supply those services and in the end
we're giving people a very flexible
architecture where we're gonna give them
very good performance and a lot of
robustness because the truth is that
there are a lot of different places
where api's need to run api's don't just
run in big data centers they don't just
run on the Google Cloud increasingly API
is run in the backs of stores you know
API is a run in you know in airports
there are all kinds of places where
these API backends live and we want to
be able to put a component of the API
management system in all those places
now I want to go a little bit to talking
about the lifecycle and the demo we're
gonna talk about we think really that
all API is go through a very similar
lifecycle like this um we're gonna start
at the top with API design but we're
gonna move on to how you actually design
your API and how you share that API
design with others how you actually turn
that API into something that's on the
Internet how you add layers of security
to your API using industry standards how
you publish your API to create a
developer portal and a web presence
developers can use to sign up for your
API what to do if your API gets a lot of
traffic how is it gonna scale how are we
gonna monitor what's going on and get
analytics so we can understand how the
API is going to be used and there are
lots and lots of ways to monetize api's
and one of the ways is of course to
charge for API calls and if that's an
option that works for your business
that's something we're going to talk
about as well so we're gonna start that
and we're gonna kind of trade off a
little bit on the demo and switch from
one to another but we're not gonna
switch just yet I haven't said the magic
word um so let's start with design and
faith Paul's gonna be sort of the the
person who does this and I'm gonna ask
him some questions but you know I'm I'm
an API developer I've heard of swagger
here a lot of and
here about something called open API
which sounds like a less exciting way to
say swagger but as I understand it I can
design and I can describe my API in open
API and if I do that there's all kinds
of things I can do to generate cool
documentation and to share my API
documentation with other people can you
show us a little bit yeah absolutely
so you're right open API is a great way
to be able to share what a API does it's
an excellent contract which can be used
to not only create API but also share
that across different developers so they
have a common sense of what an API looks
like can be okay we're on the demo
screen out here so what you see out here
is I'm logged into a PG edge this is the
air PG edge cloud version looks exactly
the same like when you would deploy it
on premises I mean everything it's a
brand new FH experience this is a user
interface they actually released just
about a few months back and it is
centered around the API lifecycle so in
this case I'll do a little bit of level
setting here I'm connected to the demo
file org think about or give a short for
an organization and it's the container
where I as a business unit or a team or
a company for this small enough will
build all my api's and add some policies
okay so the very first thing we're gonna
do is start off with taking a speck in
this case I'm going to take the liberty
of leveraging a spec that is called open
API for hotels it's a very simple spec
which is sitting somewhere in the in the
internet in this case happens to be just
a simple gist or not github account so
let's go to the app ugh screen so that
spec that yamo was the design of my API
so as a developer I might I might use it
to also generated or I might just type
you type type right exactly
okay so it all starts from the spec
editor so I'm in the tool I click on the
spec icon and let's go import the spec
so I'm just going to paste the URL that
I just picked up from there and say
import
and reviewing the demo gods are with us
today it should in a few seconds
actually show you how the hotel's open
abs spec looks like so Greg as you can
see out here it spits out some very
important information out there such as
on the left hand side talks about what
the host name is the base path is but
more importantly this is information
that gets synchronized left right so
everything you want to know right on the
right I have a nicely formatted set of
docs for my API exactly and then more
importantly if we now start examining
this this simple API doc it very clearly
describes what this API should be doing
in this case we have certain resources
which have been declared out here such
as how do I query a specific hotel right
so you have different kinds of options
provided to your there options to kind
of update hotels in this case so we're
going to use the backdrop of a hotel as
an example and then you also have the
ability for you to actually get a list
of all hotels so Greg as you as we just
kind of were discussing the open API
spec gives you the ability to
communicate your intent and in this case
the open API editor or open API is used
to be earlier known as swagger is
integrated right into the product once
you have imported the spec you can
actually collaborate with other API
developers in the team so they can edit
make some mods perhaps add some changes
and then you can take it to the next
step of that publishing or to actually
creating an API okay cool and I should
point out that open API is an open
standard it's controlled by the open API
foundation on the version 2.0 is the
version of the spec that we're looking
at here
there's a version 3.0 that's in the
works and about to be published that
takes into consideration a lot of the
inputs people have had but we've been
working with open API for a couple years
now and we found that it's become the
de-facto standard and essentially the
most popular format out there for a for
API specification you know there are
some cool things you can do with it you
can even generate SDKs for various
languages from the open API spec which
is sometimes something that's very handy
to be able
to do so let's go back to the slides for
a sec and so we talked a little bit
about the spec and what open API is and
how it is so once I have a spec you know
now what do i do how do I actually turn
this now clearly you know I'm a
developer I probably wrote some node
code or something to implement my API
maybe I wrote some node code that uses
postcards and I deployed it to Google
Cloud or wherever doesn't really matter
where I deploy it but I now want to have
all the API management goodness and all
the serviceability of appaji around my
API so so how do I do that yeah so
that's a great point so now you're gonna
focus on great I have some design using
an opening API spec how do I take it to
the next level of actually building an
API proxy okay so let's switch over to
the demo please alright so I have an API
using actually using a simple click I
can click on the generate API proxy
button I can give it the base path let's
call it v1 slash reservations and again
all I'm doing out here is it has picked
up all that information from the open
API spec in this visit I'm just making a
few changes because I would like for the
API proxy to be deployed in a very
specific way you can see there the
backend endpoint this actually happens
to be an existing API endpoint so if I
was to go out here and query this this
is exactly the backend API that Greg was
just talking about this is running
somewhere in the cloud could be the
Google Cloud could be any other data
center doesn't really matter this is the
end point that we're going to create a
proxy in front of and then we'll use the
API magic to add a bunch of different
things so I go back out here click the
next button and fair enough the API
proxy wizard has actually picked up all
the different resources which was
specified in the open API doc and I had
the option to say great I'm only going
to do just retrieving all the hotel for
right now so we're just going to do the
most basic API which is get slash hotels
something very very simple and in this
case I'm going to add some security a
little bit later on in the face but for
right now I just want to keep it as a
simple pass through proxy and oh by the
way by even making a simple pass through
proxy you can get a lot of visibility
and analytics on API usage so let's go
ahead and slick next here it gives me
the ability to decide where I would like
to deploy the API so let's just go with
all the default settings and hit build
and deploy so at this point in time it
has built a very simple API and I have a
brand new endpoint which is going to be
now used to start sharing with your
outside world
so instead of sending my API calls
directly to my back-end I send them to
Apogee exactly okay here's the apogee
endpoint and I'm just using a simple
rest line and this kid happens to be
postman and when I call this fair enough
it gives me the exact same result back
from the backend API so at this point of
time we've gone through two steps we
have an open API spec talk and we've
used the proxy editor to be able to
generate an API proxy which just points
to that Greg do you see something
missing out here perhaps if he if I was
to share this API endpoint with someone
else could someone perhaps abuse it yeah
I mean I also wanted to be HTTPS but I
know that's an easier yes but yes so I
mean what's to stop someone from just
you know watching this demo on YouTube
it's gonna be on YouTube right and just
you know trying to hit that thing in a
thousand times a second and trying to
screw up our demo yeah so that's a great
point how do you ensure you can keep
things in checks and balances right so
they have variety of different ways so
in this case what I would like to show
you is great I have an API and this is
where the API proxy magic starts so in
this case I've opened up an API proxy
editor this is where I as the API
developer or the API team has the
ability to put in a lot of different
controls and you put in those controls
using what we call as a
pa policies so I click on this plus step
icon and it brings up the 30 different
out-of-the-box policy that we have to do
variety of different things so we have
some traffic management policies
security some of this we're going to be
taking a look at later on mediation and
then more importantly you can extend the
platform by using some of the extension
policies so you could literally use
things like Java JavaScript or Python to
pretty much alter your own policy and
shared with the rest of the team in this
case I will use something as simple as a
spy caress policy the spike response II
think of this as a system-wide policy
which can make sure that only a specific
amount of transactions per second or
transactions per minute whatever that
rate happens to be it can control that
so that none of your back-end systems
crash and burn right as we know that DAC
and API is running somewhere it's either
in the cloud or it's running on premises
and it has some finite capacity right so
in this case I can make those quick
changes using some configuration options
in this case for the purposes of the
demo I'm just changing it to 3 per
minute what this means is do not allow
any number of API calls or only allow 3
calls per minute okay just a very simple
policy that I've added out here and at
this point of time I would also like to
call out the trace tool for those who
attended the keynote in the morning may
have seen the trace tool it was flashed
briefly the trace tool gives a very
powerful mechanism for the API developer
as I'm building out API proxies it gives
me some whiter check points and
information to make sure are the
policies which we've added in working as
expected so think about this as a
web-based testing tool throughout my API
development process
ok so I'll just leave the trail session
on I'll go back to my client
and I will call this API and when I do
this you can see that there were the
trace which was recorded here I can
hover over some of the things and gather
some whiter information in this case it
tells me exactly what was received from
the user I can hover over in this case
you can see the spy chorus policy Bailey
took even a millisecond right so many of
these policies have been very optimized
to ensure near literate network level
agency right so let's now try and
pretend that someone is trying to call
the API is more than they should and
let's see what the API platform does so
when I try to hit it a few times right
away the spy crest policy kicks in right
it was set to three per minute and in
this case it calculates they're only
going to allow three transactions per
minute thereby protecting a back and
api's okay so over to you Greg thanks so
as you can see just taking a break here
from trying to be scripted what
footballs done is is he's shown that we
can create a proxy for an API and we can
add policies now we don't have unlimited
time so you might ask questions like you
know can I customize the response that
comes back from the spike arrest policy
can I have different spike arrest limits
for different types of api's can I have
TLS turned on and required can I form
the API response like we saw in the demo
this morning and the answer is yes you
can do all those things this product has
been around for a couple of years we
have a lot of large enterprise customers
who drive a lot of sometimes obscure
requirements into it for the purposes
the demo we're not going to show every
single thing we could possibly do with
the product but we're trying to give you
an idea here but let's go back to the
slides for a sec so you know basically
what we've done is we've shown you know
hey using the Appaji edge we can now
create a proxy for the api where we can
insert policies so now instead of going
directly to my back-end and waiting to
Appaji and it's pretty easy to insert
some basic policies like a spike arrest
to give a basic level of quality of
service to my api but of course one of
the things i would think is you know gee
you know great you got a spike arrest
now the people watching on youtube
can't really mess things up but my API
still has no security and you know
that's no good I mean I I've read about
OAuth I understand that that OAuth is
one of the de facto standards for API
authentication how can I start to add
some of those things to my API without
having to learn all the complexities of
the spec and program and all myself
know that that's a great point Gregg in
fact many customers that we talked to
both 2.0 S is a very popular API
security standard right so in this
segment you're going to take a look at
how exactly we now take this API and
actually protected using an old policy
okay let's switch to the demo piece so
let's carry this thing a little bit
forward I'm going to create and add a
very simple earth 2.0 policy when I add
this you can see that I'm trying to use
the verifier access token method okay
and the verify access token method
within these what policy is actually
going to ensure that this API
whenever invoked is presented with a
valid or auth token okay so just for
kicks I'll go back to my postman client
and hit a send request and right away
you can see that it points out I need a
valid token so how do we go about
getting this token one of the key parts
of a platform is the notion of an OAuth
server
so the effigy edge actually has a
built-in Hoth server which can mint
tokens and we support a variety of
different kinds of Hoth flows right we
have the standard two legged and
three-legged OAuth flows out of the box
and because the platform is customizable
you can actually support some other
flows as well whether Apogee is the
platform that does the OAuth dance
itself or it integrates which we have in
the past with many different identity
and access management systems it can
control that mint tokens take some else
want other systems tokens and enforce
that and other stuff so in this case in
order to actually show you how this
would work I'm going to introduce a new
concept and that's of an api product so
what's an api product
APA product is actually the way you
would want to expose your capabilities
which are nothing but AP is in different
shapes and sizes to consumers so you
could think about a strategy where I
could take 3 AP eyes and only give
read-only access through what we call it
an API product so an API product and
I'll build something out here called
hotels gold and you can assign some
coders out here in this case let's say
hundred per minute and I'm going to pick
the API proxy that we just built which
is hotels in this API product definition
I can add a bunch of different API
proxies and I can also limit them by
perhaps all of these API only have get
access so I can limit what I can do with
the API as well as which parts of the
API I can call but also what I can do
with it ok exactly ok one of the other
things I could do is the exact same API
combination or perhaps a separate one I
could perhaps make a hotel's Platinum
product yeah in which case yes right and
which case give them access to more
api's and perhaps let you do more with
those API itself and perhaps up your
bandwidth 2,000 times a minute ok so
let's go ahead and save this API product
great so this is where when we talk
about the API team you also have
collaboration with not only the API
developer but the API product manager if
you think about detailed business and
API those products that's exactly what
we mean
now you can bundle these API then then
offer them to the outside world so great
I have a product but I need to be able
to showcase some level of security
access so in this case I'm going to
introduce a concept of an app think
about an app as the ability to actually
generate some API keys ok so in this
case I'm going to very quickly call this
the hotel's gold app developer here
and in this case I'm going to pick the
hotels gold product and hit save so all
what I've done so far is saying great I
have an APA product called hotels
now let me generate an app called hotels
app this is the app which has an
identifier a key ID and a secret which
you would share with the app developer
who's going to consume the API okay this
is where the consumption angle comes in
so you can pretend you have 10 partners
each one of them may have a separate app
why would you do that you would do that
so you can track them separately you can
report usage and as Greg mentioned you
can do some pretty exotic things you
could have some partners who are
subscribed to the gold product and have
access to lesser parts of the API or at
a lower quota or you can create apps
that give access to let's say the
hotel's platinum product which give you
more access to the same API is an
additional stuff for some of the other
api's once I have the app let's click on
this I have what we call as a key and
secret so what I'm going to do at this
point is as I mentioned Apogee edge also
has a full-blown auth provider in the
platform I'm actually going to use a
pre-configured token endpoint which is
enabled by default in any org that you
provision and I'm going to specify the
client ID and the client secret so what
I'm really doing out here is I'm
mimicking that I am an external client
which you have configured using an app
and someone has shared the app key and
secret with me traditionally the sharing
of the app key in secret essentially
happens for a developer portal ok that's
on the consumption side so I call this
and I'm using the client credentials
grant type which may be very familiar to
some of the folks who are perhaps API
developers already when I make a request
out here it gives me an access token so
now have an access token which can be
used securely to access the API this
access token could be timed it can also
be scoped
we're in it can give access to different
parts of the API than the product at the
product local level you can actually
configure what kind of scopes it allows
access to so let's take this access
token we'll go back to the hotel's API
proxy and now add an authorization
header here and the exact same token
that was just minted we'll place it in
the authorization header and now make a
request
oops maybe we didn't cut and paste right
let me oh that's your client ID I think
I think I may have the wrong client ID
let's go take a look here
make sure there's a live demo guys yeah
that's right okay let's see this get out
here
oh I know what the problem is
and I know how to fix it it's a demo oh
we didn't we didn't setup did we not
know there's one thing which we actually
skipped over and that was this back-end
system that I'm hitting actually has its
own security mechanism and this is all
writing the header less damn you're
talking to github exactly that's how we
can actually and let's remove that token
so here's another key thing out here as
you are minting these tokens they may be
back-end systems which happens to be in
this case which is sensitive to an OAuth
header you may want to remove or disable
that old header from here so in this
case let's go and let's remove the
authorization header this wasn't
scripted by the way just for the record
that's a live demo okay so let's go
remove the authorization header from
here so again using simple policies we
can plug this thing in and now hopefully
this thing will let me through so if you
weren't so quick on the uptake we would
have used the trace to figure out what's
going on exactly okay but we don't have
24 minutes so let's not do that
yes all right so back to you that's
really cool let's go back to the slides
for a sec so we showed how we could do
OAuth now in the interest of time we did
the simplest possible form of OAuth
which is the client credentials grant
type or informally known as two-legged
OAuth you're probably asking yeah but I
need to authenticate my end users and I
need to authenticate the end users using
my Active Directory or using my own
internal single sign-on system that's
extremely common in fact almost every
Apogee customer does that takes a little
bit longer to configure but it's all the
same kind of process you're seeing here
and it's a very common thing that we do
with our customers with OAuth but I
noticed that as we were doing this
you're kind of doing everything in the
Appaji console so you know I really want
my developers to have self-service I
don't want them to have to call you up
and have you
into that thing and push a button to
create an API key I want to push a
button and I wanna as a developer you
know have this thing work just as well
as the Google Cloud api's do so can you
show us a little bit how we might do
that absolutely can we switch to the
demo please so you're right you need to
be able to advertise to the world he's
an awesome API and the way to do that is
through a developer portal in this new
API experience they've actually enabled
that capability in the hands of
developers so I'm going to click on this
icon here and we're actually going to
build a live portal as you go along in
this demo so let's click on the plus
portal I con and let's call it the brand
new hotels API portal and you can see
this is a live URL which is being
generated as you speak let's go ahead
and create it okay so once I do that it
gives me something very basic and simple
and when I click on this it gives you a
street cards page not something which I
expected I'm trying to build a hotel's
API right so let's see how we go about
changing and customizing and show you
the power of how you can do that all
from within the tool so in this section
I can go to the pages so think about my
role changing slightly where now I
become part of the content team who's
responsible doing that and you can do
that from then the same tool a PG Edge
has our back built into it which means
you could essentially have a role or
that of a Content developer who has
access to only building out this portal
and not mess with the API proxies and
vice versa
okay so in this case we go to the home
page and we can start making some
changes here we can call it hotels
and just change it in couple places and
I hit publish okay so in this case if I
was to refresh this great I see that
change but I don't really like the
picture here it's here but odd doesn't
look like we don't have any hotels in
Chicago anyway yeah
exerting in San Francisco in New York
only so let's go change that well how
can I really do that I can go back to
the the hotel's main page out here the
portal page and I will upload some handy
files in here so first go and delete the
the default logo which has been here so
right from here I'm going to actually
add a couple of files in this case the
logo file okay I'm not a UX developer
it's all the time on that I say it's
awesome and a background which i think
is really neat
okay so now let's go back and go to the
the theme setting out here in this you
actually have the ability to change a
few things right you can change again
this is a very simple markdown kind of
format I can go change the footer the
background everything oh boy yes okay if
simply the just built on CSS I know some
some folks don't like it but again this
is very simple ones the world okay
I think I got it right let's go ahead
and publish this portal Hey look at that
and just like that I have a branded
developer portal within a few clicks and
minutes right didn't take that long but
there's something which I also would
like to add in we have a hotel's API yes
that's missing out here so let's see if
we can add that to the developer portal
yep okay so go back to the portal page
here
you can click on the API section okay in
this API section I'm going to add the
exact same hotels API spec that I had
used so let's pick the hotels gold
product because your API spec is mapped
to the product it'll go ad this
yep that's the spec we created in the
beginning of this demo right exactly on
the SunShot is ensuring that if I change
it online it doesn't immediately get
published until I'm ready for it exactly
okay so I hit save and complete one
thing I want to go check on is once you
go to the spec let's make sure the spec
is looking the way it should be
here's the hotel spec right
oops code
you're going here make sure you'll get a
snapshot of the latest one let's pick
this and see if this okay once I've done
this I want to go to the hotel's main
page okay and maybe add one more comment
to it
hotels API excellent and hit publish
okay so I just made a couple changes I
added an API snapshot and updated the
definition so if I go here and click on
this you can see the hotel's gold
product and you can also see the API
spec oh looks like it imploded I think
let's move on interest of time okay
it's supposed to be here yeah so works
with this you would actually see the API
documentation render out here in a very
similar way better oh yeah as we had in
the spec editor not consumer perspective
now can I actually sign up for a key
here and get that API key in credentials
we saw earlier yeah so we haven't
enabled that but okay in real world what
you would do is you would take this to
the next step and the same API key and
secret that I actually generated from
the API provider side you could have a
developer portal through which you can
expose that capability and have them
generate the API key in a Cell services
right right and we're not gonna go into
all of that in the interest of time but
that's exactly why this ability to
create a portal and the customization of
the portal is very simple the portal is
it's just a web app that calls the
management API is an edge everything
we've done in the UI has an Associated
API we have a portal here which is um
you know kind of built into the product
and very easy for customers to deploy
but we've also had customers build their
own portal in their own way completely
custom with heavy input from their
branding teams on top of our management
API and really everything in between so
you can get going very quickly as frith
polish showing and from any API so
that's all you need but you also have
the ability
to do extensive customization so let's
go back to the slides and we're gonna
talk through a few more sections of the
life cycle a little bit more quickly but
we wanted to get the real you know the
basics of the whole product there now
once I've done this I probably want it
to scale and you know I got to assume
that the Apogee edge product running as
a service can auto scale that runs on
top of Google Cloud it even runs on top
of Amazon Cloud all those capabilities
allow us to take advantage of auto
scaling and some of the interesting
things you can do with edge as a service
we've done a lot of work to make sure
that it's not only scales but it's very
reliable so for instance everything in
the product is is replicated across data
centers we use technologies like
Cassandra remember we run in a lot of
different places not just the Google
cloud which allows us to have things
like ooofff tokens and quotas and things
like that work even in the failure of an
entire geographical region and our
customers who run on-premises they
almost always run in their own data
centers and they almost always have more
than one data center and none of them
has asked us actually one person asked
us for the old traditional you know
failover disaster recovery drill on the
weekend thing what they want is
everything to be active active across
their data centers at all time now this
this chart here shows the common case of
auto scaling which is you know most API
is just like most web apps have a chart
that looks kinda like this you have big
traffic Peaks Monday Wednesday Thursday
and Friday and whatever geography you're
in you have smaller traffic Peaks on
weekends and it's pretty predictable and
auto scaling systems like the ones built
into the cloud can easily keep up
because every 10 or 15 minutes the kind
of average what's happening and they
they add servers and take them away an
interesting use case is we have some
customers whose peak does not look like
this so for instance we have a customer
in the clothing industry that does
auctions of items of clothing
periodically so for instance at 9:00
a.m. on Thursday the locks in a new
limited edition item of clothing to
their fans who will use their app to try
and get this item of clothing and their
API traffic goes from one or two
requests a second to 10,000 requests a
second in the space of about a second
these kinds of auto scaling algorithms
don't work there because there's no auto
scaling and system in the world that can
detect you know traffic ramping up over
a 2 or 3
period and spin up you know 50 or 100
server nodes so we also have the ability
through our global support center to
configure sort of what the parameters of
this auto-scaling are an Apogee edge you
know we send cell to a lot of large
enterprises and some of them you know
like the idea that they can call someone
up and say hey you know we have a big
event happening tomorrow morning let's
make sure we're ready let's kind of
adjust those auto scaling parameters in
order to make this sort of thing happen
that's a real important thing that we do
now if we move on of course this none of
this would work if we weren't monitoring
so I talked about the scaling I talked
about all those kinds of things but
obviously within our global support
centers we're monitoring what's
happening not only with the cloud we run
on great cloud platforms but with our
own application you know our certain our
certain API is using an excessive amount
of traffic and we've gotten to the point
now where we have great people working
behind the scenes as well as a lot of
automated monitoring where we often
detect problems with a customer's
back-end API before they do and
sometimes we call them and say hey we're
noticing a lot of errors from your API
we're noticing that the API traffic is
coming to Apogee but it's not
necessarily getting to you and they say
oh you know look at that we're having a
problem um so it's it's a very
interesting world that we live in where
we're kind of sitting in the middle of a
lot of API traffic but since we're
sitting in the middle of this API
traffic there are some interesting stuff
we can do about analyzing it all the API
calls passing through averaging we can
gather metadata because we do things
like ooofff and api key validation we
can record for you which developers
which applications which geographical
locations are accessing the API the most
and allow you to do some interesting
things in order to run your API program
remember in a lot of cases you may have
an API product management team that is
actually trying to turn this API into a
product and even if it's not even if
it's just for customers or partners it's
very important that you understand what
are the most popular API is what kind of
SLA am i achieving or my API is very
slow do they have a high error rate are
are certain applications more popular
than others are there giant changes has
an application suddenly gotten wildly
popular which might mean either you have
a hit on your hand
or someone has compromised some
application credentials and they're
trying to use the API in a way that's
not supposed to be used so for all these
reasons there are a lot of analytical
capabilities in the product and let's
see if we could take a look at how those
work and what kind of information you
can get sure let's fit to the demo
please so back to the air pH UI you can
click on the analyze tab and this give
you options around many out-of-the-box
reports that are generated by default by
the platform so I was talking about you
know you have an API proxy that's built
as API traffic is piping through the
through the Gateway we collect a lot of
different kinds of metrics many of them
we kind of publish out-of-the-box in
terms of these reports so very first one
out here is the API proxy performance
report now this gives you a very broad
idea of how the API proxies are doing
and which means the general general
model API traffic piping trail system in
this case I have a few different API
proxies that are deployed in this org
and we can see the total traffic coming
out through here and in a very quick
snapshot the kind of number of errors
the percentage of error so on and so
forth you can also see the amount of
time which is being spent in the API
proxy versus the average chaga response
time so the amount of time that Apogee
might be taking to execute those
policies I put in exactly in mine
policies are sometimes simple things
like spiked arrests or sometimes they're
my own JavaScript code or my own Java
code and that can be any number of
milliseconds that's right exactly so
this starts to give you a good idea of
the kind of things you should be doing
within the API platform certainly we run
into situations where customers are
doing some heavyweight transformation
there's some other tools which are
really good for that your API platform
is clear of agility this is your face to
the outside world you want to keep it as
quickly as possible process as many
transactions as possible there are bunch
of different reports which you're not
going to go through today but again you
can check them out you know we have a
free trial account which anyone out here
can sign up for today but what I am
going to touch on very briefly is the
notion of custom reports so although a
lot of these are the Box reports
great but many times you had the
requirement if think about API has
become your channel your digital channel
business wants to know what kind of
orders but I am i processing right what
kind of Hotel Reservations have gone
through this so you need the ability to
be able to create custom which can be
presented to this is user in this case
I'll just give a very simple example of
a custom report in this case it just
shows you the amount of traffic coming
in from different AP is no DD ApS could
represent different business segments
such as orders such as payment so on and
so forth and using some simple
heuristics we aggregate the data and
then he had the ability to canal dissect
through this and figure out what's
really going on with the api's you can
delve deeper we have a bunch of
different kinds of metrics out here if
you were to click in the Edit tab here
you can just add different
out-of-the-box metrics which are
available at a high level right all the
traditional stuff that you can expect to
be you can also see some custom
dimensions out here these are the ones
which you as an API developer can have
the ability to create some custom
dimensions so imagine we capture usually
any information that can be gleaned on
from the header information or any kind
of commonly available user agent stuff
that's available but as an API developer
within the API proxy you can actually
add policies such as a statistics
collector policy and ever start scraping
out all the useful analytics that you
need in this case the order amount and
the order discount right once you do
that you can add various kinds of
dimensions and you can see the amount of
stuff that's available to you some
common dimensions which you can slice
and dice using the geographic region
region that you're coming from any
specific developer app perhaps who's
calling it you can use some custom
dimensions out here and many of the
advanced dimensions are available for
you to use by default once you do this
you actually have a very simple report
which can then be shared in a secure way
by different kinds of users and of
course the reports have api's exactly so
you can bring the version API ok cool
back to you so
back to the slides for just one more
second so that's that's how the
analytics work so we've got some real
comprehensive capabilities there and the
last thing is they'll talk a little bit
about money I want to make some money on
my API now it turns out there are a lot
of ways to make money on your API back
in our hotels API
I might make money by having people stay
in my hotels or sometimes I make money
because my API drives other product
sales but you know I might be doing
something really interesting I might be
in finance and I'm trying to do a market
data API those folks are actually next
door or I might be in the news and I
might charge a lot of money for
extremely extremely timely news or who
knows what I might want to actually
charge per API call and have different
tiers and different kinds of prices for
different API calls is there a way that
I could do that
absolutely let's switch to the demo game
please this is actually by design going
from slides to demo just to make sure
you guys are up I don't think the person
taking the screen apart is not by design
but that's ok ok so let's use a live
example in this case right I'm going to
very quickly talk about Pitney Bowes
which should also mention in the keynote
and this happens through a developer
portal so i give you a very broad and
very high-level example of how we could
take and build a developer portal this
is another example of how they taken the
developer portal and customized it and
they also happen to leverage some of the
monetization capabilities of the a page
platform if you think about monetization
once you hit a level of maturity in your
API and you want to make money off your
API which would seem natural at some
point you can use some of the
monetization capabilities provided by
FEG edge we are going to review the
consumer side of it but from the
producer side or the providers are of
api's you can create different rate
plans right because you may want to
offer a pis so that people can consume
based on different kinds of dimensions
perhaps you want to sell api is using
volume based pricing right
maybe these new number of API calls per
month or you may want to charge
separately for each transaction or you
might want to do revenue sharing where
you give developers money for building
apps that use your API exactly so Walt
means another example of how they use
revenue share when they have their
partners who are sending business to
them so the developers get a cut of that
transaction
okay so in the spit knee--balls
developer portal you can see they have
different kinds of api's I'm going to
click on the geo Search API and click on
pricing plans this gives you the
consumer side of it so if you are an app
developer trying to use some of the
Pitney Bowes api in this case geo search
you can sign up for different kinds of
plans in this case they are doing volume
based pricing where you can get 5k 10k
etc and different credits and in this
case you can build custom plans so this
gives you one glimpse of how you can use
monetization both from the provider side
and in this case from the consumer side
- now monetize your api's so what's the
credit is that like I get different
points for different API calls exactly
so this K there they have this notion of
some kind of a premium tier where when
you're using a higher tier they give you
more and more credits so that upside for
the developers oh I see that's and to
use more and more ap is exactly and
different API calls could have different
weights essentially right exactly okay
awesome so back to you okay so back to
the slides one last time so what we've
done really is we've gone through the
whole lifecycle of API as we talked
about everything from designing a spec
and publishing this Bacchus
documentation to creating an API proxy
and adding policies so I can have some
of the different levels of service
around my API without changing what's on
my back-end talked about how to create a
developer portal and actually publish
that API for use by developers how I can
use analytics to find out how my API is
being used and if I want to charge for
my API like Pitney Bowes is doing using
the apogee edge product how we can do
that as well so you know basically
that's what we do with apogee edge we
provide a product that allows people to
configure all of that stuff to work the
way they need it so thank you all for
coming thanks for trying
[Music]
you